[Music]  now that the world has been introduced  to beyoncé and jay-z's twins how her mom  and dad adjusting a life at home or like  just found out from Grandma herself miss  Tina knows Lawson the world was finally  introduced to those beautiful  grandbabies of yours I mean you guys  just must be over the moon yeah we are  there was some confusion over the name  so help me clear it up we've got a girl  named and a boy named well you know one  baby is a lot of work I can't imagine to  power jay-z and Beyonce adjusting to  life at home with three kids now you  can't forget the firstborn right how's  blue IV doing as a big sister she  enjoying her younger sibling Airy proud  and very excited she's a great big  sister she really cares for them  [Music]